Bob you know what's interesting this the
the idea of your character Saul getting
a spinoff series was suggested on your
first day of shooting is that right as I
recall it the scene with Brian and in
the lawyer's office
yeah where Saul's introducing himself
somebody shouted out behind the camera
can I get a job on the sequel yeah and
everyone laughed at the notion I mean so
I don't know if that started things but
Vince very quickly started talking about
there's more to the character maybe then
we're seeing in this show yeah it's
interesting this has been an amazing
transformation for you because for years
a conic comedy performer and working is
you know solely in the sketch world now
you're getting nominated every year
Coenen actually it's interesting a long
time ago when I was starting out I was
part of a I did some acting III was part
of a duo an acting duo and acting do
well yeah it's it hasn't caught on it's
an acting team an activity two people
and one provides the facial expressions
yes and the other okay now I know all
right
Adi Goes Down I have a head shot from my
team from quite a long time ago yeah
there we go there's me it was one of the
dumbest things we came on we performed
that at the Victory Gardens theatre in
chicago 1988 and we would go on stage
together as thespians that so
specialized that i would do all the
physical facial stuff and you would make
noises it was the dumbest well it was so
fun but it wrapped us up and you would
get underneath me to my head with a
microphone and I would just make stupid
cartoony faces and you were like oh damn
but people it was really fun to do it
was a hot
you